on this episode we have a pocket
[Music]
[Music]
this is
Gary B hey everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is so 104 of the
askgaryvee show
alright by the way I think I said
episode weird in that intro so I gotta
go back and listen to that but I won't
and number two who somebody tweeted me
today and said why don't you pull
questions out of a hat which I thought
was clever so India that's correct right
you don't you don't have the name of the
person I can tell by the look on your
face so that's okay person has said that
at least I replied instead a good idea
uh and so we will do that Jeff Rivera
great suggestion so now the spit bucket
that used to be used for wine is now
gonna be used to pull out questions for
the askgaryvee show yeah I guess that's
it I guess we have a we have
company-wide meeting coming up so the
backgrounds a little bit different than
normal which I like a little change of
pace who everyone's doing well really
enjoying the show feels like it's
picking up some momentum seeing a lot
more sharing of the show in social which
means a huge fat thank you to all of you
there was also a subtle guilt trip to
the ones that aren't doing it earn India
let's get this show the first question
is from this person
it's from Lloyd you know I'm probably
not the right person to answer this
question for you because that's
something that never even remotely
crossed my mind or has ever entered into
my body I love the climb the income
level that I was at was never something
that could ever be a variable in me
becoming lazy or unmotivated you know I
would question if that even matters
maybe you're good maybe you're good I
mean like to me if I ever hit a day
where I'm not fired up to keep climbing
the mountain I think that I would
actually listen I think it's partly
actually
um it is 100% possible that somewhere
out of nowhere for business reasons
obviously health issues in my family
could be the other variable but for
business issues if I woke up and I was
good and I started becoming lazy I would
probably retire and I'm throwing a curve
ball here like this is a real answer I
think you may be thinking that I'm
joking like you may read a blog post
that just says I'm done
hey it's me remember I said to hustle 24
so I'm out I'm out and I'm going to do
this because if that feeling ever
entered my body that's what I would do
it you know to me I think the bigger
question is don't get robbed by me or
other people or live the world or the
life that other people tell you to live
maybe you should just check out maybe
you're done
maybe you're just done which is sounds
kind of nice you know I you know maybe
he's done so you know I don't I don't
know how to motivate that because I
never knew how to I never would know how
to get into that zone in the first place
I just have no answer to that my
intuition is you're making your money in
a way that doesn't inspire you and that
you should go and do something that you
really want to do and if you sell the
money vibe for it why don't you go to
Hawaii and start surfing all the time
and then try to build a surfing business
on the back after you serve for a little
while something like that that feels
practical real India
I like this India reading it you're like
my Vanna White Ben then that's a great
question
I think you create a face and you can
create a face by renting a face a lot a
celebrity or an influencer or you could
go the tony the tiger or the Jolly Green
Giant route and I still think that Leo
Burnett 2.0 and Leo Burnett is the
classic ad agency in Chicago that was
really known for this critten B's
characters the Marlboro Man the Keebler
elves I think companies are not doing
enough of create something out of thin
air and then allow it to be the face I
think it's time that we brought back
characters in businesses and I think you
can do it in a lot of ways I mean I
think we see it with like a
app logos right like it's a little koala
bear it's a little elephant like turn
that person person turn that thing into
an animated character I think it'd be
really spooky slash rad if some you know
chick with a huge elephant mask looks
like answering you and obviously look
you could answer in human form the way I
do or you could actually create the
animation of that person I mean I think
an animated character replying in video
form on social would go bonkers and
explode and so those are the two ways
very practical advice rent it with a
celebrity hey Drake do this for us for
the day and people will be pumped and
you're siphoning Drake's equity but
you're renting or do the hard climb
create out of thin air
the next caricature I give good advice
guys I mean can I say it is episode 104
of a show named ask a Gary Vee people
like it
don't act so goddamn surprised I'm
telling strength okay good I like Adam
already cuz there's a brother on the ego
train and I love the ego train I equally
like the humility train that's the
balance that I try to live and comes
natural to me Adam I think that you need
to shut the [ __ ] up and just pick one
and go do it
if you've so many goddamn strengths one
of them is clearly not moving fast
enough if you're even debating this your
strength on moving and creating action
is clearly not that strong so I would
say that's a great thing that fires me
up and I believe that people have
multiple talents I mean I I feel like a
lot of people do I'm flabbergasted by
somebody not just picking one and moving
forward I'll give you I'll give you
better advice cool you've got a lot of
strengths lay them down look at them say
I like that one the best do that right
maybe if somebody got them strength just
pick one and free him then win start
winning you can get to all of them
eventually you know I mean God
No yeah
dear Gary I'm just too good too many
things help yeah I mean right pick one
dick Jesus by the way I'm pumped I like
actually think he's gonna win like I
know where I'm being a little dinghy
you're being a little dinghy like Adam I
I'm pumped just pick one man just pick
one and start winning it tastes good
it's delicious all right that one is
exciting I mean like why wait oh good
news share that's a good one what's the
best thing that's happened to me this
week first of all thank you so much
second of all love the concept of this
Twitter account good news share like
just share good news like what's the
best thing to happen to you this week oh
that's a nice concept I'm into that uh
the best thing that happened to me this
week if you consider Sunday the
beginning of the week I guess you should
since officially I think that's the way
it actually is is it it is right I
forgot this is that real life though
something is the 'true like yeah right
it's not in normal I would say the best
thing that happened me this week was
spending time with my kids and being
official on Sunday they really enjoyed
the outdoors we went to we've rent the
place for summer and I've city kids and
they're starting to get older and it was
fun to watch them kind of play in the
yard and really enjoy that experience
and like spending real quality time with
them it was it was oh I'd one of them
this is not a joke I had one of the best
weekend's of my life this last weekend
all predicated on family time it was
fantastic
and and that was the best part just
seeing you know my kids are we should
turn six this week
Xander turns three later this summer
they're starting to get that phone age
it felt different it felt different it
felt like I thought I think I saw a
preview to the next four or five years
of fatherhood that really excited me
yeah dear ox phone goes off during that
emotional moment
kind of horse timing I like this hat
thing this is but there's one right it's
kind of different by this whole show has
different vibe because of a bucket
shapes everything the bucket has changed
at all
Warren Warren when dealing with clients
would you rather find new clients or
hashtag Hustle okay very good Warren I
like that so so I call this hunting and
farming do you want to hunting it new
ones do you want to farm and grow the
ones you have I think way too many
people don't realize the answer is both
why not both Warren why not both and
when you're super duper duper duper
talented you can do both that's how you
go from 30 to 500 people in a flash
there's no rather Warren I just want
both like like you know you want both
you wanna you want a hunt you want both
you want both that was like let's keep
going I like cause I like one of my
vibes out of this buck I think the
buckets gonna maybe get people to a slap
five is my lucky number I don't know if
I wanted start doing six but okay guys
look social network have to do to make
it rivals book Twitter Instagram Steph
step what they were gonna have to do is
win the 12 13 14 15 16 year old
imagination there's no winning after it
hits a certain point social networks
over the next foreseeable future in my
opinion have to win the youth they need
to make snapchat feel like that person's
older brothers app and this new thing is
even cooler and that's how you win in my
opinion I think you have to under
arbitrage or build off of utility I
think people don't recognize how much of
a utility Instagram was Instagram made
everybody better photographers which
brought a huge huge group of people and
then it started getting social so my two
answers are under arbitrage the 12 13 14
15 16 year old or build a utility that
starts to the utility builds a big vase
and then slip it and create the social
network underneath it yeah it was a good
answer
question today what do you think about
the bucket you keep asking questions
I'll keep answering it
hello everybody this is stefan and this
is the a step on d rock and India show
episode 104 and she's in fact about the
number 104 it is I am after 103 and
before 105 as you can see we're set up
for in all hands or about to get that
going and talk a little bit about being
are alright see the worry is one and
that's about it
India let's get into the show it's just
a my answer to this puking emoji is that
I could draw a better puking emoji next
question India oh you guys thought you
guys can get it on television show with
YouTube's we've all this
ask Gary B
you